hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu was würde ich eher oder
irgendwie so dies ist eine website auf
der man zwei verschiedene
auswahlmöglichkeiten bekommt man muss
sich für eine entscheiden was man eher
machen würde bei diesem ersten beispiel
wäre das in einer riesigen in einem
riesigen vier sich leben oder in einem
riesigen schuh omx ein gott im 40 ist es
halt so am anfang ist es aber irgendwann
fängt das ding an zu schimmeln oder wird
aufgegessen oder so in einem schuh das
stinkt von anfang an
ich würde aber trotzdem den schulnamen
okay ich bin in der minderheit 1 40 lebt
doch nach drei tagen aufgegessen ist man
einfach verdammt noch mal tot
den schuh ist noch nicht gut vielleicht
tritt jemand mit seinem fuß in mich rein
aber egal im gefängnis für ein jahr sein
oder in einer kompletten isolation in
den bergen für ein ja oh mein gott okay
würde ich lieber im gefängnis ein jahr
sein oder komplett isoliert von der
menschheit ich sage mal wenn ich genug
zu essen und zu trinken hätte in den
bergen würde ich definitiv in die berge
gehen weil das wollte ich schon mal
machen irgendwie so ein zwei wochen
einfach wegfahren einfach weg von allem
nur die natur 70 prozent marke
wallhecken slater hallo
schönen guten tag
oh mein gott dies verdammt nochmal
verstimmt dass der polizei hinten der
hängt da übrigens nicht mehr weil der
garten wechselseitig den gestern hatte
und ich habe mich gemalt im regen ok
dies ultras schwierig würde ich eher
überall glatze haben also komplett
harmlos sein oder komplett albino weiß
albino sein da kann ich wenigstens meine
haare behalten aber glatzköpfig ist dann
wieder ich ihm definitiv glatzköpfe dass
ich will schon wieder der mehrheit ihrer
textilien challenge of technical und
challenge also irgendwie city and
challenging wie seine sohnes im keller
oder so di gallo challenge irgendwas mit
milch ich finde dieses jahres der
mehrheit
ok 400 dollar heute direkt bekommen oder
jeden tag für 200 tage einen dollar
bekommen
definitiv das zweite das ist vielleicht
für die gut die jetzt rund 100 dollar
haben wollen
ich stelle doch bei beiden oder ich
würde trotzdem die haie gehen weil ich
glaube es gibt auch vernünftige haie die
auch schon wieder eine überzahl ich
glaube es gibt auch ein paar friedlicher
also wenn ich mir die haie aussuchen
dürfte würde ich auf jeden fall diese
haie mit denen man eh schwimmen würde
ich für den rest meines lebens lieber in
einer bibliothek leben wo bücher eine
form der unterhaltung sind oder in einer
gefängniszelle wo man den zugang zu
jedem tv channel hat war ich in meinem
leben komplett wenig leser würde ich
definitiv das erste wählen schon wieder
in der mehrheit die kommentare darunter
sind auch zwei interessante sache und
zwar hätte ich lieber einen riesigen
kopf im vergleich zu meinem restlichen
körper oder hätte ich lieber die ganzen
einen topfschnitt juli hat sich klein
war hat dich voll an der zeit zum top
schnitt der hier einfach so aufgehört
hat ich will euch aber keine bilder
zeigen weil ich weiß nicht ich finde es
ein bisschen zu privaten wenn ich euch
kinder fotos zeigt ich mag auch nicht
diese ganzen challenges von wegen hey
kinderfotos von mir das ist irgendwie
weiß nicht dass mir zu privat aber hier
können sie mir gern glauben ich sah
damals echt komplett scheiße
da mein kopf im vergleich zum restlichen
körper relativ klein ist würde
jetzt ist die jetzt wenig verblasst und
ich meine hände hochheben ich bin ich
einfach gelb ich würde auf jeden fall
dass das dass das erste ist eine relativ
leichte sache ich würde auf jeden fall
den lamborghini wählen oder das ist
relativ ausgeglichen sogar tatsächlich
alternative fragen wenn ich meine eltern
hören würde würde ich die lieber hören
wie sie sex haben oder wie sie sich
streiten
definitiv wie sie sex haben was was
wollt ihr denn alle dass ihre eltern
stress haben damit kommen jetzt auch
schon zur letzten frage für heute und
zwar würde ich lieber ein vampir sein
oder ein werwolf 50 50 damit bin ich
dieses video bei der damen herren ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen wollt ihr
vielleicht eine zweiten partie sah dann
was wäre wenn ihr die auswahl hätte